the nice is in Fort Worth Texas hi
Denise how are you I'm well thank you
how are you better than I deserve what's
up okay so my husband and I are on baby
step three and he still has some active
credit cards open though he's not using
them and he doesn't want to close them
and I don't know if it's just something
I should let go or if there's some
advice that I could pass those in well I
think it's probably incorrect to say you
you and your husband are on baby step
three you are but baby step three would
involve those accounts having been
closed already so he's not he's letting
you he's tolerating you doing this isn't
he I would say he's on board with it as
well doesn't look like it to me
you just called me and said he's got
open credit cards how's that on board
well he thinks that they will just close
on their own over time because he's not
using them why does he think that I
guess because they let them already have
no they don't close well I mean they
might but um why do you need why why let
them close them what's the purpose of
that I know what's the purpose of
everything open yeah it doesn't make any
logical sense we know it's not logical
why it doesn't make any logical sense so
I mean if you're if you're going to do
this plan now if you want to your own
plan that's okay but if you're going to
do this and say you know we're on baby
step three I'm bought in this is what
we're doing we're getting rid of credit
cards and have debit cards we're not
going into debt anymore and we would you
know pay them all off and close them up
and cut them up and it's fairly simple I
guess you could ask him I mean why he's
being illogical because it's not this is
not logical um considering he says he's
on board but he's not and so I asked him
you know what is it you want from these
credit cards you want to use them again
I mean you just hold them back just in
case just in case you decide you want to
go back into that I mean why are we
keeping them open why why why why yeah
because it doesn't make sense you know
and if he answers you
you can deal with that I guess but it
might be that it might be that he is has
got the secret you know wish to go back
into that again someday I don't know or
I might need them I might need them for
an emergency or what about travel or you
know they bring up all these stupid
things that you know if you've got an
emergency fund you have a debit card you
don't need them for an emergency or for
travel right right
well so I guess you got to just find out
what the theory is behind this because
it's not it's not congruent with what he
says he's doing is that logical yes that
makes sense and I do think it may be
kind of fear-based of what if I need
them yeah here's the thing let's just
you know we can almost laugh at this but
let's pretend that you cut them all up
and you closed all the accounts and you
had an emergency fund and let's pretend
that you wanted a credit card how fast
do you think you could get a credit card
oh pretty quick about 30 seconds one
phone call to your bank it would be
issued on the phone you know unless
you've got unless you file bankruptcy
last week you know but I mean in your
condition and your in your financial
condition you know you look over you got
thirty thousand bucks in your bank
counting your your checking account in
your emergency fund you pick up the
phone and call your bank and say hey we
want to visit Visa card can we swing by
and pick it up they'll print it at the
branch and hand it to you okay you know
I mean I know they will so if you want
to go back in that it's not hard and run
by the car lot and pick up a car on the
way over you know I mean it how hard is
it to go back into that is easy getting
out what's hard well so if you just had
oh oh I need a car I'm willing to have a
car payment you run over the car lights
you leave with a car you can walk onto
the car lot to drive one off long as you
got a driver's license I mean somebody
will sell you a car is some interest
rate they'll issue you a credit card on
the spot you know and so it you know if
you want to go back to that way of
living it's really easy to reverse this
process so that's what I would do it's
kind of a funny thing to think about but
that's why I would look at it this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]